(upbeat music)
♪ How does a website platform,
educational, and non-profit ♪
♪ Shot in a cramped, damp
shoe box of a closet ♪
♪ As an office built
by a Bengali trooper ♪
♪ This product turned out
to be the school house ♪
♪ Of the future ♪
♪ The naught recruit, hedge
fund suitor without a suit ♪
♪ Got a lot astute, by
chasing a lot pursuit ♪
♪ By gracing his wrestling roots ♪
♪ Harvard Mass Tech Institute ♪
♪ By 30, his niece needed
a teacher substitute ♪
♪ And every day while lessons
executed and en routed ♪
♪ Graphed waves, unit converted,
and computed square roots ♪
♪ Inside, he was longing for
something of a job reboot ♪
♪ This uncle was ready to
help, coach, tutor, recruit ♪
♪ 15 cousins in sight, so
many lessons to unite ♪
♪ Our guy saw his future
scale, scaling up the fight ♪
♪ Put a pencil to his tablet,
connected it to his mic ♪
♪ And he spoke his first insights,
in video and sound bites ♪
♪ Well, the word got around, she said, ♪
♪ I pray for you at night, Sal ♪
♪ Despite son's conditions ♪
♪ You get through and
make them bright now ♪
♪ Get your education at
your pace day or night ♪
♪ And the world's gonna know your site ♪
♪ What's your site, Sal ♪
♪ Khanacademy.org ♪
♪ My site is Khanacademy.org ♪
♪ And there's a million
things I haven't taught ♪
♪ But just you wait, just you wait ♪
♪ He needed cash, he wanted alg,
cal, stats, maths 1 until 8 ♪
♪ But he was halfway through
his savings, one day Ann said ♪
♪ I'll pay, and the Doerrs
and the Gates, they gave way ♪
♪ And now he has a team and
they actually get paid ♪
♪ SAT and AP, and physics,
chem and biology ♪
♪ He promised to you would
keep them always free ♪
♪ So we all achieve a voice saying ♪
♪ Sal, other countries don't understand ♪
♪ He got it translated and made
in every language in demand ♪
♪ The couldn't get calculus from books ♪
♪ But in a video Sal drew limits ♪
♪ And they understood, miraculous ♪
♪ Even thought didn't know how he looks ♪
♪ They started learning',
stirrin' all their friends ♪
♪ To get online, too, ♪
♪ But teachers wanted learning outcomes ♪
♪ So he felt inclined to ♪
♪ Scannin' for evidence
researchers in his radar ♪
♪ Planning' for effect
size in comms and PR ♪
♪ In his closet with his
intellectual repertoire ♪
♪ On YouTube you can be a new star ♪
♪ Just you wait ♪
♪ On YouTube, YouTube, ♪
♪ Khanacademy.org, Khanacademy.org ♪
♪ There's so many videos to learn ♪
♪ Why does Sal teach online
like he's running out of time ♪
♪ Oh, Khanacademy.org, Khanacademy.org ♪
♪ The online world turns to you ♪
♪ Did you know that schools gone closed ♪
♪ And now teaching's done virtual ♪
♪ The world will never ♪
♪ Be the same ♪
♪ Oh the speech on-stage at TED talks ♪
♪ See if you can spot him ♪
♪ Just you wait ♪
♪ Preaching on mastery by
learning from the bottom ♪
♪ Just you wait ♪
♪ He isn't teaching solo now,
an army now has sought him ♪
♪ We worked with him ♪
♪ We, we hosted him ♪
♪ We, we trusted him ♪
♪ We, we loved him ♪
♪ And we, we're the
donors that funded him ♪
♪ And there's a million
things I haven't taught ♪
♪ Just you wait ♪
♪ What's your site, Sal ♪
♪ Khanacademy.org ♪